Setting goals is the first step in turning the invisible into the visible, Tony Robbins.
The power of setting goals has long been known as a vital tool champions use for turning
their dreams into reality.
Where we choose to direct our time and energy on a consistent basis will determine the results
we achieve.
My ability to concentrate and work towards that goal has been my greatest asset.
Golfing legend, Jack Nicholas.
There are three basic types of goals that you can set, long, medium and short.
Each of these goals plays an important role in continuing to move you towards your ultimate
destination.
Let's begin with long term goals.
Setting a long term goal is great for guidance and motivation as it helps build an inspiring
vision that you can work towards over time.
Having a long term goal is what allowed former world number one tennis player Pete Sampras
to make the shift at age 16 from a double handed backhand to a single hander, which many people
believe to be a risky move at that stage of his career.
In Pete's case, the longer term vision he had for his tennis game helped steady him
as he went through the short term uncertainty of making the change.
Tip, make sure your long term goals are your own and that they truly excite and inspire
you.
Next, set a medium term goal, allowing you to work towards something which is not too
far away.
For many athletes, this is typically 90 days, but will vary on your sport and the type of
goal you want to set.
Medium term goals help you track how you are progressing towards your larger goal and you
can think of them as many milestones that you are aiming for along the way.
Next up, short term.
Creating and tracking lots of smaller short term achievable goals is vitally important
in building confidence and momentum as you steadily move towards your medium and long
term goals.
As you focus on achieving the smaller goals that are within your direct control, you may
find you are wasting less attention worrying about winning and losing and instead directing
your energy into what will actually help you become better.
Steffi Graff, winner of 22 Grand Slam singles titles, set it like this.
You can't measure success if you've never failed.
My father has taught me that if you really want to reach your goals, you can't spend
any time worrying about whether you're going to win or lose.
Focus only on getting better.
The smaller achievable goals help you do just that.
According to Terry Orlick, author of The Pursuit of Excellence, achieving the outcomes always
comes back to focusing on the doing, which means acting on the day by day, step by step
goals.
Congratulations, you have completed your overview on goal setting.